napoléon bonaparte est une part de nous
si emmanuel macron n'a pas négligé cette
partie de l'histoire de france à
l'occasion des commémorations du
bicentenaire de la mort de l'empereur
aux invalides
il a également dressé un portrait moins
flatteur dénonçant par exemple ses
fautes comme le rétablissement de
l'esclavagé
lalor le chef de l'état at il su trouver
le ton juste pour évoquer cette figure
qui ravive les controverses ce sera
l'objet de notre face à face
un journaliste français enlevé au mali
le porte parole du gouvernement l'a
confirmé serait aux mains d'une branche
locale d'al-qaïda olivier dubois aurait
été kidnappée le 8 avril par le groupe
de soutien à l'islam et aux musulmans
dans une vidéo de 21 secondes pas encore
identifié s'adresse à sa famille ses
amis aux autorités une enquête
antiterroriste vient d'être ouverte en
france
la colombie véritable poudrière une
semaine de contestation populaire qui a
fait au moins 20 morts 25 commissariat
de quartier ont été attaqués hier dans
la soirée à bogota la capitale
à l'origine du mouvement
un projet de réforme fiscale finalement
retiré et communauté internationale a
lancé un appel au calme
[Musique]
emmanuel macron a donc commémoré
aujourd'hui le bicentenaire de la mort
de napoléon l'empereur c'était un l'âge
de 51 ans sur l'île de sainte hélène
dans l'atlantique le 5 mai 1821
estelle farges on vous retrouve en
direct des invalides était organisée
donc ces commémorations aujourd'hui
bonsoir on l'a dit commémoration qui ne
fait pas l'unanimité manifestement
exactement stéphanie car le personnage
est controversée attirant pour ses
détracteurs héros pour ses adorateurs
vous l'aurez compris tout comme est
cette commémoration napoléon bonaparte
ne fait pas l'unanimité mais l elysée
avait prévenu dans cet exercice il
s'agissait je cite de regarder en face
cette être complexe en étant ni dans la
géographie ni dans le déni ni même dans
la repentance commémorer ce n'est pas
célébrée nous at on dit en marquant ce
bicentenaire emmanuel macron ne se
dérobe pas a précisé le palais je vous
rappelle que ses prédécesseurs avaient
plutôt fait preuve de prudence sur le
dossier à l'image de à jacques chirac
qui en 2005 avait refusé de participer à
la célébration du bicentenaire de la
victoire d'austerlitz toujours est il
que pour cette commémoration à visée
pédagogique comme elle a été décrite
emmanuel macron s'est rendu en fin de
journée à l'institut de france où
étaient présents des académiciens et des
as lycéens s'en est suivi un dépôt de
gerbe au pied de la tombe de l'empereur
sous le dôme des invalides et bien sûr
juste avant cette commémoration
elle a été a marqué 1 par la prise de
parole du chef de l'état un discours
attendu et puis aussi scruté 1 puisque
emmanuel macron est aussi le premier à
chefs d'états à s'exprimer sur un appeau
leone depuis à pompidou c'était en 1969
à l'occasion du bicentenaire de la
naissance de l'empereur alors justement
reste elle peut pourrait-on retenir de
ce discours
et bien c'est un portrait tout en clair
obscur un cadre et c'est emmanuel macron
à l'image de l'oeuvre total de
l'empereur qui n'a pas livré tous ses
secrets mais qui continue de nous forger
c'est par ces mots que le chef de l'état
a terminé son discours emmanuel macron
qui a rappelé vouloir elle livrait une
commémoration éclairé avec la volonté à
de ne rien céder à ceux qui entendent
effacer le passé au motif qu'il ne
correspond pas à l'idée qu'ils se font
du présent sur l'esclavagé rétabli par
napoléon
emmanuel macron a déclaré à que la
deuxième république a réparé en 1800 à
48,7 trahison de l'esprit à des lumières
il a aussi condamné à l'exercice
arbitraire d'un pouvoir solitaire mais
le chef de l'état a aussi salué les
qualités à deux législateurs de stratège
et de bâtisseurs de l'empereur napoléon
pouvait être à la fois l'âme du monde et
le démon de l'europe a résumé emmanuel
macron merci estelle farges en direct
des invalides à emmanuel macron alors a
donc finalement fait le choix de
commémorer ce bicentenaire de la mort de
napoléon mais le président at il su
trouver le ton juste les mots justes lui
qui mettrait tout le monde d'accord
c'est l'objet de notre face à face
[Musique]
avec nous pour en débattre louis georges
tin militants et essayiste bonsoir avoue
christian bourdeilles à vos côtés
présidente du souvenir napoléonien
bonsoir à tous les deux messieurs merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
regardez notre histoire en francs en
phase 1 c'est ce qu'a dit emmanuel
macron dans son premier discours avant
l'hommage aux invalides hommage dont 100
célébration on a bien précisé
du côté de l'elysée il a trouvé le ton
juste emmanuel macron pour vous
christian bourdeilles en tant que
président du souvenir vous êtes restés
sur notre faim
écoutez moi je suis satisfait des propos
du président il se devait d'être modéré
dans ses propos faire la part des choses
moi je retiens une expression puisque
j'ai eu la chance d'être à l'institut
est de pouvoir l'écouter en direct pour
moi c'était un grand moment on
l'attendait aussi pas simplement ceux
qui sont critiques mais aussi ceux qui
sont plutôt favorables donc à cet
héritage et ce qu'il a dit là dire où
nous avons renoncé au pire de lempire et
omeyer de l'empereur va écouter je pense
que c'était cet exercice difficile qu'il
fallait faire mais moi je globalement je
suis satisfait rien de désagréable
entendre a été dit bon ça manquait
peut-être un petit peu de souffle parce
que quand même
l'épopée des napoléonienne c'est une
grande épopée qui
très romantique aussi bon donc
sas a manqué un petit peu mais je vous
le dis en tant que président du souvenir
la pologne qui espère toujours un peu
plus peut-être de légende dorée et je
hais la légende dorée le roman national
moi je l'assumé totalement parce que il
est constitutif de ce que nous sommes et
nous sommes là aussi pour essayer de
rêver au destin de la france
et quand on rêve au destin de la france
bat on s'appuie notamment sur l'épopée
impérial louis georges tin le même avis
vous voilà on imagine que vous étiez
plutôt critique et puis on attend
peut-être face à ce discours
quel est votre sentiment ce soir il faut
rappeler une abolition est associé à
trois crimes majeurs un crime politique
le coup d'état du 18 brumaire des crimes
de guerre et contre l'humanité de
rétablissement de ce cavage
par conséquent il faut l'enseigner car
c'est un personnage très important mais
lui rendre un hommage déposer une fleur
devant sa tombe
me paraît une chose à digne et monsieur
macron va dans cinq jours
célébrer l'abolition des esclavages
après avoir célébré celui qu'il avait
rétabli le en même temps a quand même
des limites
je trouve que c'est quelque chose
effectivement absolument insupportable
et il est le président qui divise
il fallait marquer des choses on pouvait
faire une exposition c'est très bien
enseigner oui mais pourquoi est il
besoin de s'y rendre
voilà la question que je pose et je
trouve qu'il s'est rendu à digne ou de
la célébration qui aura lieu dans cinq
jours
indigne d'une célébration c'est le en
même temps qu'ils ne passent pas
christian bourdeilles quelle est votre
réponse
alors c'est pour assurer mon
interlocuteur que je sais pas la chance
de vous de voir alors je le rassure
parce que les célébrations où les la
commémoration ne se termine pas ce soir
et vous savez qu'il ya quand même le
projet de pendre un cheval en plastique
au dessus du tombeau de l'empereur et
tout ça pour qui parait-il ré humaniser
la figure de l'empereur napoléon 1er
donc je rassure totalement
donc on interlocuteur la tentation de
dénigrer de rabaisser la figure de
l'empereur
va va bientôt apparaître encore une fois
par ce projet de pendre un cheval en
plastique au dessus du tombeau de
l'empereur qui est pour moi quelque
chose là pour le coup on reprend les
mêmes termes qui est particulièrement
intolérable et je ne comprends pas
d'ailleurs que le président de la
république pour le coup est autorisée
donc cette oeuvre dit-on artistique je
respecte toutes les oeuvres artistiques
bien évidemment mais pendre un cheval en
plastique qui normalement doit
correspondre au cheval de
mme arago que napoléon aurait abandonné
à waterloo ce qui d'ailleurs
complètement faux sur le plan historique
ça c'est quelque chose qui est tout à
fait désagréable donc et j'espère que ce
projet n'ira pas jusqu'au bout donc en
tout cas s'il va jusqu'au bout mon
interlocuteur peut être complètement
rassuré donc là dénigration donc de
l'empereur est bien aussi au programme
est encore au programme
même si encore une fois je l'espère ce
projet n'ira pas jusqu'au bout avant de
vous faire réagir louis georges tin
voudrais vous faire écouter un premier
sont pas encore entendus 1 et napoléon
pour lui et une part de nous écouter
napoléon bonaparte est une part de nous
parce que l'action et les leçons du
guerrier du stratège du législateur
autant que du bâtisseur porte encore
c'est ce qu'a notre siècle louis georges
tin quand vous entendez le président
dira napoléon est une part de nous vous
vous sentez quand même un petit peu
concernée ou pas du tout c'est une part
d'histoire de france est contestable le
mans ou encore une fois il confond
célébrer et enseigner qui fait
d'enseigner oui le célébrer non rendre
un hommage
moi je dis comment pouvez-vous faire
france lorsque les héros d un sur les
bourreaux des autres et on a eu le même
débat en france il n'ya pas très
longtemps finalement il ya quelques
décennies sur pétain certains disaient
oui il faut quand même commémorer pétant
a pas le célébrer on voit bien
l'hypocrisie de ce genre de formules la
dernière répété en france a été enlevée
il y à peu près 20 ans donc c'est ce
même débat qui en france à l'espagne par
exemple sur franco lui aussi est un
général caf un coup d'état
eh bien les espagnols après un débat
national ont eu le courage de dire il
faut rendre la dépouille de franco à sa
famille et à la place du tombeau
monumental qui lui étaient accordées
faire un bus et je pense que pareille
aux invalides faudrait faire un musée de
l'histoire des républiques pourquoi pas
on parle beaucoup de valeurs
républicaines et en même temps on
célèbre le fossoyeur de la république
moi je dis façon paisible spartoo sport2
république dans l'histoire ça vaudrait
le coup d'être enseignée et rendons
respectueusement le corps de napoléon à
sa famille parce que ce n'est pas à la
république de financer le tombeau du
fossoyeur de la république
alors question bourdeilles c'est vrai
qu'on n'imagine vous n'êtes pas du même
avis est ce que l'on m'a justement à
napoléon est il en danger aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que et on n'avait pas rendu
hommage au président n'avait pas rendu
hommage depuis georges pompidou ça ça
date un 1969
vous admettez que ça peut devenir
compliqué je comprends pas forcément que
ça peut devenir compliqué que qu'on
fasse de l'histoire moi ça me dérange
pas du tout au contraire
et encore une fois comme le président de
la république l'a bien dit il ya des
zones d'ombré et pas faisons l'histoire
mais faisant l'histoire c'est à dire il
faut pas juger a priori et j'espère que
les enseignants donc justement donc de
la république prenne le temps donc de
regarder qu'elle est l'oeuvre de
napoléon ans comme moi je reviens
toujours au code civil
le code civil que les révolutionnaires
n'ont pas été capables de mettre au
point ces le premier consul qu'il l'a
mis au point ce code civil qui règle
toute notre vie de la naissance à la
mort c'est à rien ça et je suis désolé
encore une fois sont pas les
révolutionnaires alors comparé
maintenant napoléon au maréchal pétain
je vous rappelle quand même que françois
mitterrand homme de gauche je crois
déposés chaque année donc une gerbe de
fleurs sur la tombe du maréchal pétain
alors heureusement aujourd'hui on a
arrêté sa mai
je pense que l'occasion du centenaire de
la mort de l'empereur napoléon 1er il
fallait quand même rendre hommage cet
empereur il est connu dans le monde
entier
tout le monde le connaît à travers le
monde vous dessinez le chapeau de
napoléon tout le monde sait que c'est
napoléon bonaparte et qu on dise c'est
l'homme de la révolution c'est lui qui a
fait que la révolution française s'étant
créés de manière définitive dans notre
histoire
alors je sais bien que ça peut déplaire
ça peut poser problème mais c'est quand
même d'une certaine façon la faillite de
la révolution française dans ses débuts
et heureusement que le premier consul
donc a rétabli l'ordre la liberté et
surtout donc l'espoir parce que c'était
aussi l'espoir de pouvoir vivre dans de
meilleures conditions
et encore une fois le cas chez l'oréal
le dac que nos enfants vont bientôt
passer
je suis désolé le dax c'est napoléon les
lycées c'est napoléon
donc c'est comme pas mal du tout un donc
d'avoir un chef d'état qui s'intéressait
beaucoup donc à l'éducation dont des
enfants
mais encore une fois il faut pas
regarder napoléon bonaparte avec nos
yeux de 2021
il faut faire de l'histoire pour
regarder exactement comment les choses
se sont passées george washington
donc à des plus de 200 esclaves on n'a
pas des baptisés la capitale des
etats-unis pour autant donc encore une
fois il faut faire la part des choses et
je reconnais encore une fois la qualité
du discours du président de la
république qui de ce côté là était tout
à fait intéressant est que moi j'avais
qu'accepte qui
volontiers encore une fois il y à des
départs dont comme n'importe quel
parcours à ics ont pris des grands
révolutionnaires leppard ombre de de
fidel castro de che guevara de lénine
bas ça existe aussi donc
regardons tous à et ne faisons pas une
fixation sur cette part d'ombré de
l'empereur roll je les reconnais bien
évidemment et quand on voit toute
l'oeuvre donc de napoléon c'est que
c'est vraiment très vraiment grandiose
christian bouteilles en bas écouter
justement un sco dit emmanuel macron lui
même face aux critiques notamment à
gauche à cette décision de commémorer
écouter au fond de lempire nous avons
renoncé au pire et de l'empereur nous
avons embellie le meilleur commémorer ce
bicentenaire
c'est dire cela simplement sereinement
sans céder jamais à la tentation du
procès est anachronique qui consisterait
à juger le passé avec les lois du
présent justement louis georges tin sur
cet aspect ne pas céder à la tentation
du procès anachronique vous l'accordé ça
au président de la république parce que
comme nous l'a dit christ en bouteille
c'est un personnage qui fascine jusqu'au
au delà de nos frontières qu'elles
soient fascinant c'est un constat
évident mais ce n'est pas avec les yeux
d'aujourd'hui qu'on le juge puisque déjà
à l'époque évidemment déjà été choqués
je rappelle que l' esclavage avait aboli
en 1794
donc lorsque napoléon le rétabli c'est
un scandale
pas seulement pour les esclaves et pour
beaucoup de français de l'époque
par ailleurs quand on parle de pardon
brrr je suis extrêmement choqué par ces
formules qui vise à effet misé un crime
contre l'humanité n'est pas une pardon
excusez moi c'est une manière de dire en
gros c'est un petit détail c'est une
ombre au tableau
mais non ce n'est pas une ombre au
tableau c'est un crime contre l'humanité
voilà il faut vraiment dire des choses
et je pense que c'est mépriser et grande
partie non seulement des noirs de france
mais tous les gens qui sont humanistes
quelle que soit leur couleur seront
choqués comme moi que l'on dise cette
part d'ombré
en fait c'est vrai que d'humanité donc
on peut pas dire ça par ailleurs je
voudrais rappeler que même les acquis
que nous chante lee laudateurs de la
peau
du point de vue des territoires la
france est beaucoup plus petite qu'elle
ne l'était avant le coup d'état
on perd donc la louisiane qui
représentent 20% des états unis ça
dingue bien entendu mascareignes et
c'est donc même quelqu'un qui est
nationaliste de rester c'est une
catastrophe
ensuite le code civil en réalité repose
sur la ségrégation raciale puisque
napoléon précise que les droits ne
seront pas les mêmes selon la couleur de
peau de contenu 10 est une merveille
jeudi c'est une merveille de racisme du
temps lorsqu'on nous dit par exemple l'a
fait la banque de france je dis oui
c'est une grande banque qui est fondée
sur des acquis négrier les trois quarts
des fondateurs la banque de france qui à
l'époque est une banque privée sont des
négriers des armateurs donc voyez le
bien qu'il fit il le fit mal et le mal
qu'il fit il le fit bien votre réponse
en question beauté
le problème de l' esclavage est un
problème beaucoup plus vaste et il a
duré pendant de nombreuses années il
existait avant d'un napoléon bonaparte
pendant des siècles et des siècles on
reproche absolument pas aujourd'hui aux
sultans ottomans d'avoir été des
esclavagistes
monsieur erdogan aujourd'hui en turquie
veut donc faire renaître l empire
ottoman la pression de l' esclavage
personne ne lui en parle bien évidemment
quand vous le savez la traite donc a
existé pendant de nombreuses années
donc entre les pays du moyen-orient et
les pays africains
je crois que justement c'est l'honneur
donc de l'europe occidentale avoir posé
le problème la pauvre c'est qu'on en
parle aujourd'hui j'aimerais bien qu'on
en parle de la même façon en turquie et
dans les pays du moyen-orient et y
compris donc en afrique car on sait très
bien que commencer s'est effectuée cet
esclavage qui était je reconnais bien
évidemment un crime que le contre
l'humanité alors je voudrais revenir
quand on dit ben on a en a vendu la
louisiane oui bah effectivement moi je
suis pas un colonialiste donc la
louisiane sait très bien qu'elles
étaient vendus donc aux états unis bien
évidemment quant aux autres possessions
heureusement que napoléon n'a pas été un
colonialiste parce que le pouvoir le
plus colonialiste et quand même la
république française donc de ce côté là
moi je regrette rien bien évidemment et
je peux pas regretter je suis pas
nationaliste encore une fois moi je veux
qu'on fasse de l'histoire moi je suis à
la tête d'une société historique
s'appelle le souvenir napoléonien et ont
fait de l'histoire on regarde les choses
et c'est ça qui est intéressant en
faisant l'histoire je suis pas là pour
cacher les choses
encore une fois la pole et ont aboli la
traite en 1815 c'est quand même lui
napoléon à libérer les esclaves à malte
en egypte y compris sa politique de
libération dont des juifs dans toute
l'europe grâce justement à ces idées de
potes civils dont vous demandez donc
donc aux juifs de toute l'europe
aujourd'hui ils vous diront que c'est
napoléon qui a libéré le ghetto de
berlin le ghetto de varsovie qui
existait déjà à cette époque là c'est un
libérateur et que l'on veuille ou non
encore une fois il n'a peut-être pas
tout réussi jeu il faut la part des
choses cette wii et emmanuel macron
lui-même n'a pas occulté cette zone donc
je vous propose justement de l'écouter
sur le thème de l'esclavagé
napoléon en 1802 vous l'avez là aussi
évoqué a rétabli l'esclavagé que la
convention de 1794 avait aboli en 1848
avec victor schoelcher la deuxième
république à réparer cette faute
cette trahison de l'esprit des lumières
c'était quand même très attendu louis
georges tin notamment dans les dom tom
où il ya plein de descendants d'esclaves
il ne s'est pas caché pour le coup
emmanuel macron il a eu le courage de
dire voilà c'était une faute
vous appréciez quand même justement
cette partie c'est pas vraiment un
courage n'avait pas le choix
la vérité c'est que pendant très
longtemps la géographie autour de
napoléon à cacher cela il a fallu dix
historiens très courageux pour dire la
vérité et qui était insulté au départ on
leur disait vous crachez sur l'épaule il
disait mais je fait que rappeler les
faits donc si aujourd'hui le président
rappelle les faits c'est parce qu'il y
avait des gens des historiens qui se
sont battus pour faire reconnaître cette
vérité qui était vraiment caché de déjà
il faut le noter donc il faut rendre
justice aux personnes qui ont fait ce
travail et puis deuxièmement moi je lui
dis quand on est le pays des droits de
l'homme on ne peut pas être en même
temps le pays qui célèbre les gens qui
dénoncent qui violent les droits
l'homme ya un moment il faut avoir un
peu de cohérence un peu de dignité
donc c'est pour cela que je dis on ne
peut pas rendre hommage à l'auteur de
trekkopje mann heat et c'est un petit
peu comme la question du détail de
l'histoire
on se rappelle monsieur le pen qui nous
disait bon bien sûr il ya eu la shoah
c'est un détail de l'histoire alors
quand on lui dit napoléon
il est formidable après il ya eu
quelques petites pardon je trouve que ça
ressemble un peu et ce n'est pas très
digne donc arrêtons avec ce vocabulaire
de la part d'ombré
appelons un chat un chat déjà à l'époque
les révolutionnaires disait que c'est un
crime de lèse humanité que veut faire
des ravages
je ne sais pas d'hier matin que date
cette incrimination
donc aujourd'hui je le dis si on veut
véritablement créer de l'unité dans ce
pays il faut choisir des héros qui sont
rassembleur ce n'est pas le cas napoléon
à l'évidence la preuve on se débat les
avons quantité d'hommes et de femmes
héroïques dans ce pays on peut en
choisir d'autres
pourquoi choisir celui là simplement
parce qu'ils flattent si vous voulez la
volonté de puissance
l'héroïsme facilit clinquant et on se
fiche finalement du droit de la liberté
des valeurs républicaines
je trouve que ce n'est pas 10 merci en
tout cas à tous les deux louis georges
tin question bordel on ne mettra pas
d'accord mais c'était ça la richesse de
ce face-à-face merci à vous d'avoir été
en direct sur rt france première
audience d'examen aujourd'hui des
demandes d'extradition pour plusieurs
italiens expatriés en france accusé de
terrorisme de l'autre côté des alpes
ces anciens militants d'extrême gauche
dont la plupart ont fait partie des
brigades rouges ont été interpellé le 28
avril dernier réfugier dans l'hexagone
depuis longtemps il risque plusieurs
années ils ont à rome les explications
de notre reporter katia technique
les membres des brigades rouges sont
visées pour des faits de terrorisme qui
se sont produits entre les années 70 et
80 en italie les fameuses années de
plomb les brigades rouges était un
mouvement terroriste d'extrême gauche
qui lutté pour les droits des
travailleurs et aussi contre la menace
d'un régime autoritaire en italie mais
au prix du sang avec des attentats des
enlèvements des homicides
un certain nombre
deux membres des brigades rouges
condamné en italie s'était réfugié en
france depuis de très nombreuses années
et ce en vertu d'une doctrine la
doctrine mitterrand qui leur avait
permis de rester sur le territoire
français s'il avait renoncé au
terrorisme mais cela avait empoisonné
les relations entre paris et rome
et c'est sous la pression des autorités
transalpines qu emmanuel macron a
autorisé une opération en vue de les
extrader
donc cette membre des brigades rouges
ont été interpellé le 28 avril et 2 se
sont rendus un autre est en fuite
en tout cas elles ont refusé leur
extradition je vous propose d'écouter
deux avocats des brigadistes quand vous
êtes libre depuis près de trente ans en
france et vous travaillez ou iv
normalement et quand vous renouvelle vos
papiers vous pensez pas qu'on va vous
travaillez à ce moment là surtout qu'on
a retrouvé le discours original de
mitterrand il ya aucune exclusion pour
les crimes de sang suffit de regarder
c'est dans les archives de les viser
c'est pas très compliqué je ne dis pas
que il faut tout oublier je dis qu'il
faut tirer un trait sur l'histoire
laborde et dire ce qui s'est passé en
italie et comprendre un peu ce qui s'est
passé toute la jeunesse italienne était
en dissidence et par conséquent on peut
imaginer qu'on dans une situation
pareille
il ya du courage politique pour voir
cette question-là l'aborder et en tirer
une série de conséquences une forme d'
amnistie ou ou de réparations pour les
victimes évidemment aujourd'hui la cour
d'appel les a convoqués à 16h bové de
commencer à étudier le demande
d'extradition dont ils font l'objet la
procédure peut durer plusieurs mois
voire plus mais neuf membres des
brigades rouges ont depuis le coup de
filet était relâché sous contrôle
judiciaire
mais leurs papiers ont été saisis ils
resteront en france le temps de la
procédure au tribunal
ce fut donc cet après midi un défilé de
personnes assez âgées dont marina
petrella dont nicolas sarkozy avait
refusé l'extradition en 2008
on écoute sa réaction je suis atterré
c'est ce que je faisais du rat et je ne
suis pas en mesure de soutenir les
réactions en france l'elysée a salué un
moment historique et le garde des sceaux
eric dupond moretti a dit n'avoir
strictement aucun état d'âme tandis que
jean-luc mélenchon s'étaient émus de ces
arrestations ainsi que la ligue des
droits de l'homme prince est avec nous
dans quelques instants nous parlerons de
la disparition du journaliste olivier
dubois home a dit le porte parole du
gouvernement l'a confirmé il aurait été
enlevé le 8 avril dernier à gao par le
groupe de soutien l'islam et aux
une enquête antiterroriste a été ouverte
par la france ce soir
et puis direction ensuite la colombie en
proie depuis une semaine à des
manifestations contre la politique du
gouvernement
[Musique]
mais en fait mine ici des commis tous
les deux à trois jours en france
actuellement pourquoi il shoote ont
encore à protéger totalement les femmes
on dit souvent femme posée en parler
briser le silence
nous savons que seulement 18 19 % des
femmes révèle les violences qu'elles
subissent donc ça veut dire qu'il ya 80%
de femmes qui ne révèle pas les
violences qu'ils subissent aux forces de
sécurité dont celle qui rêvait il faut
vraiment les croix et les protéger
souvent on met toute la responsabilité
sur la victime
c'est la question de quels sont les
moyens que l'agresseur a mis en oeuvre
qui doit être posée et la loi le dis
très clairement
et souvent on détourne la loi par cette
histoire de consentement on voit bien
qu'on est quand même encore très loin
très loin de ce qui est nécessaire pour
vraiment pouvoir avoir les moyens de
protéger les femmes
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins
dulong vieux cash nous vous parlerons de
tout sans langue de bois
[Musique]
les accords d'abraham changer les
équilibres stratégiques pour le
moyen-orient après 50 ans d'immobilisme
dans cette région complète drogue était
le seul à pouvoir créer les conditions
d'une paix durable grâce à ses relations
différentes avec tous les acteurs
le problème est maintenant de voir
comment joe biden va traiter un sujet
s'il relance l'accord actuel des accords
d'abraham resteront une alliance
stratégique contre l'iran tu n'iras les
pays de la région et réglera les
relations avec israël
l'europe se cantonne dans le rôle de
spectateur sceptiques en ayant
totalement minimiser la dynamique créée
par les accords de bras si tout se
déroule comme l'envisageait donald trump
et ses négociateurs 2020 n'aura pas été
seulement l'année de lakovic 19
elle sera aussi celle des accords de
branche
[Musique]
20h38 les bienvenus en direct sur rt
france si vous nous rejoignez le porte
parole du gouvernement confirme la
disparition homélie du journaliste
français olivier dubois collaborateurs
de différents médias gabriel atteint
ajoute que les services effectués
actuellement les vérifications
techniques d'usagé sur la vidéo
circulant sur les réseaux sociaux où le
journaliste explique avoir été enlevés
le 8 avril à gao par le groupe de
soutien à l'islam et aux musulmans dans
l'enregistrement de 21 secondes il
s'adresse à sa famille ses amis aux
autorités pour qu'ils fassent leur
possible pour sa libération
une enquête antiterroriste vient d'être
ouverte en france et goûter le
témoignage d'arnaud projet responsable
du bureau afrique à reporters sans
frontières
ce qu'on peut dire c'est que c'est un
journaliste aguerri qui connaît bien mal
il travaillait depuis
il travaille depuis plusieurs années
donc c'est quand même un fin connaisseur
de la région il a très bon très bonnes
relations et de très bons réseaux sur
place des accès qui sont aussi voilà
privilégié de par le fait qu'il y
travaille depuis depuis très longtemps
le 8 avril lorsqu'il est à lorsqu'il
était à son hôtel à gao il est sorti
pour un rendez vous visiblement qu'il
n'ya pas revenue après le déjeuner qu'il
avait prévu de revenir à bamako à
l'issue du reportage ou de l'interview
de la séquence qu'il était un parti
couvrir
il avait prévu de revenir deux jours
plus tard à bamako il n'a jamais pris
son vol retour c'est une zone
extrêmement dangereuse pour les
journalistes sans doute l'une des plus
dangereuses au monde désormais
évidemment contenu de la zone plus les
jours et les semaines ont passé
concernant sa disparition plus nous nos
inquiétudes se sont se sont renforcés et
elles ne font que quatre conforté avec
cette vidéo dans laquelle il affirme
avoir été kidnappé le 8 avril avec
évidemment la précaution de dire cette
vidéo pour l'instant n'a pas été
authentifié où l'on connaît pas encore
la source exacte et que les autorités
françaises continuent à parler d'eux
de disparition et pour en parler nous
sommes avec abdel karim yoda ou cui
chercheur associé au groupe afrique de
l'institut prospective et sécurité en
europe
un bonsoir monsieur merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france olivier
dubois est apparemment en vient aux
mains du groupe de soutien l'islam et
aux musulmans
que sait-on de ce groupe à c'est un
groupe qui a été créée par la fusion de
plusieurs différents groupes en 2017
et ça c est se sont un peu éparpillés
dans toute la zone et qui sont contre un
gain en concurrence avec al qaïda au
sahara donc c'est un groupe qui mène
beaucoup d action qui détient déjà des
otages
je crois qu'ils ont encore quatre otages
à la disposition c'est un coup très dur
pour le journalisme une semaine après
l'assassinât des journalistes au burkina
et ces journalistes qui a comme alain
forget l'a dit tout à l'heure qui a des
réseaux très très approfondie est sûre
avec les aime les djihadistes montre
très bien que ce dia 10 ton monte d'un
cran dans le niveau des répressions et
de la radicalisation
pour autant il n'y a pas encore de
revendication officielle est ce que cela
vous étonne qu est ce que ça veut dire
en effet mais le côté positif c'est que
le fait qu'ils ont diffusé la vidéo
montre très bien leur volonté de pouvoir
vouloir soient négociés soit demander
des rations soit demander la libération
des prisonniers ou même c'est de
dialoguer donc le fait qu'ils ont même
montré de la vidéo c'est un bon signe
qu'il est en vie et que c'est un signe
peut-être de dispositions à pouvoir
discuter ou par les fasse un très bon
signe parce qu'on a vu que les
journalistes espagnols et qui ont été
assassinés au burkina cette charge n'a
été donnée alors il y a quand même au
moins six ans on compta au moins six le
nombre d'otages occidentaux détenus au
sahel
ils poursuivent tous le même but selon
vous un effet la méthode et de ce groupe
là c'est sa spécialité c'est de prendre
en otage et négocier et demander des
rançons contrairement à al qaïda al
qaeda souvent usd et quittent leurs
otages dans cette pratique et cette
méthode
est une méthode de ce groupe qui fait
peut-être en utilisant ses otages pour
pouvoir se renforcer
avoir des moyens de renforcer sa
capacité de nuisance dans la zone on a
entendu ce membre de reporters sans
frontières expliqué tout à l'heure que
c'était une zone extrêmement dangereuse
pour les journalistes certainement
maintenant la zone la plus dangereuse
sur la planète
gao on le rappelle ou a sans doute été
enlevés olivier dubois pourtant l'armée
française est sur place ça veut dire
quoi qui a une forme d'échec dans ses
réalisations sur le terrain
en effet c'est un pied de nez carrément
c'est carrément une insulte à tous cas
et était ko abrite la plus grande base
militaire de la minustah de berkane qui
compte propre et 5000 hommes et 6 7 dans
cette même ville des médias disent tu
arrives à enlever des journalistes ça
veut dire que tout l'effort la stratégie
qui a été mise en place cette stratégie
une réponse militaire est insuffisant si
les jeunes et les terroristes et
continuer à pouvoir encore à recruter
dans la population à s'installer à même
assez fendard parmi cette population
cela montre qu'il fallait que la
stratégie de la lutte contre le
terrorisme doit changer
il approche de développement de l'
approche humanitaire et sociale doit
compter plus la réponse militaire unique
ne suffit pas été déployés à
pratiquement maintenant dix ans rien n'a
changé étant donné qu'aujourd'hui
l'ensemble du territoire malien est en
zone rouge à risque 'cela montre très
bien que cette stratégie est
insuffisante et qu'il fallait renforcer
par des mesures économiques sociales et
même de communication auprès de la
population pour éviter que cette
jeunesse où cette population puisse être
sensible à ces arguments de cette police
aujourd'hui le gouvernement malien a
conscience de cela et souhaiterait faire
changer
la stratégie en effet le croque le
gouvernement malien a déjà des contacts
avec le groupe étant donné que la
libération de l'otage française ce fip
et ronan et de soumaïla cissé a montré
bien qu'il ya quand même de contacter
des discussions avec ce groupe et le
gouvernement lié à un moment donné a
même souhaité d'avoir une autre approche
des 10 de dialogue et même convainc que
c'est cette auris la délaisser ses
schémas et des de revenir dans la
légalité mais je crois que c'était pas
l'avis de tous les acteurs qui sont
engagés dans cette lutte contre le
terrorisme mais je crois qu'il fallait
pour pouvoir éradiquer ce fléau
il faut utiliser tous les méthodes
possibles et diversifier les approches
afin de pouvoir couper la source même
l'alimentation des sites terrorisme et
ces journalistes qui a été enlevée
justement c'est un journaliste et
spécialiste avec des questions
sécuritaires
il essaye de comprendre les dynamiques
qui alimente à ce phénomène ces fléaux
de conflit ces fléaux qui alimente le
terrorisme et c'est pour cela que je
crois que le fait qu'il a été arrêté
marc très bien une grande inquiétude
pour ceux qui arrivent et c'est très
mauvais pour l'opinion publique
internationale et nationale parce qu'il
n'y aura plus d informations si les
analystes
plus à l'est et cela s'est passé
malheureusement deux jours après la
journée internationale de la liberté de
presse justement c'était ma dernière
question peut-on s'attendre à une
recrudescence des attaques contre les
civils occidentaux ou contre les
journalistes dans la région il ne faut
plus y rendent selon vous un effet il ne
faut plus s'y rendre étant donné que
même si le journaliste qui ont des
réseaux qu'un de contact même la
confiance de certains liens qu'ils ont
avec ses trois enfants maintenant
kidnappé je ne vois pas comment les
citoyens où les touristes peuvent
s'attarder à à s'est baladé dans ces
régions étant donné que plus personne
n'est pas année à l'abri et en même
temps les acteurs des chaos
les fonctionnaires de l'onu où les
fonctionnels de la ministre n'a cessé
déplace avec des gardes du corps et des
véhicules blindés
combien de fois des touristes peuvent
aller n'a pas vraiment que ça qu'il faut
faire très attention et que les et que
les états fassent plus d'efforts afin de
diversifier les merci beaucoup a bloqué
gomis chercheur associé au groupe
afrique de l'institut prospective et
sécurité en europe merci à vous en
colombie à présent la situation est
toujours très tendue d'importantes
manifestations violemment réprimées
secoue le pays depuis une semaine en
cause un projet controversé de réforme
fiscale finalement retiré grégoire douce
et les manifestations ne faiblissent pas
et la crainte de nouveaux heurts
subsistent selon les ong trême blu ray
ce la répression violente des autorités
a causé 31 morts depuis le début de la
contestation le 28 avril et plusieurs
centaines de manifestants ont été
blessés ou portés disparus
le fossé se creuse entre le pouvoir et
les protestataires et la police y sava
ina c'est pas la violence policière est
inacceptable totalement inacceptable car
elle n'est pas justifiée contre des
personnes qui ne font que brandir des
pancartes
prenons le cas extrême de personne
jetant des pierres et de personnes
allumant des feux de joie
rien ne justifie de tirer rien ne
justifie d'attenter à la vie d'un être
humain
c'est inacceptable la vérité que ça a
toujours été comme ça il ya toujours eu
des pressions dans la constitution il
est dit que les policiers doivent
défendre le peuple
mais ne nous ont jamais défendu jamais
ce sont des violeurs des assassins ils
font disparaître des gens
le gouvernement du président ivan
bouquet à retirer le projet de réforme
fiscale à l'origine de la contestation
populaire
celui ci prévoyait notamment une hausse
de la tva sur les produits de première
nécessité
mais les revendications s'élargissent et
la colère s'intensifie contre l'exécutif
dans le même temps le chef de l'état a
réaffirmé son soutien aux forces de
sécurité
les nations unies ont de leur côté
exprimé leur inquiétude suite aux
derniers événements nous sommes
profondément alarmée par les événements
dans la ville de cali en colombie où la
police a ouvert le feu sur des
manifestants qui s'opposent à une
réforme fiscale tuant et blessant un
certain nombre de personnes selon des
informations disponibles
l'un des prochains objectifs du
mouvement de contestation lancé par le
comité national de
eve stopper une autre réforme concernant
cette fois-ci le secteur de la santé la
situation colombie qui est suivie par la
france plusieurs dizaines de personnes
se sont rassemblées devant le consulat
de colombie à paris cet après-midi des
ressortissants dénonce les violences
subies par les manifestants après
plusieurs heures d'attentes
ils ont pu transmettre un courrier aux
consuls de colombie en france une lettre
et une action pour démontrer leur
soutien et dénoncer la répression
toutes les semaines il y avait massacré
colombie tout les masques et les laisser
melilla démord toujours des défenseurs
des droits de l'homme c'est un pays où
il n'ya pas de garantie pour la pour les
personnes qui veulent manifester à
exiger le droit de vivre une vie digne
alors aujourd'hui on s'est donné rendez
vous ici pour protester pour montrer
qu'on est avec eux qu'ils ne sont pas
seuls et différentes personnes de
différentes parties de droite de gauche
représentants des peuples autochtones
des afro descendants des étudiants des
travailleurs se sont rassemblés
aujourd'hui ici pour dire on est fatigué
on n'en peut plus et pas possible qu'il
y ait autant de violence et autant
d'injustices dans un même territoire
tout la communauté européenne comme les
états unis
il connaît très bien cette situation
mais il verse silence avant la situation
colombien c'est pour ça que l'initiative
citoyen de tous nos coloniale qui est on
habite à l'extérieur nous sont là ici
pour manifester
c'est ta situation qu'ils sont vivants
aujourd'hui en colombie à des
répressions des assassinats des
disparitions de toutes les libertés vite
et de tous qui a passé dont les conflits
en main d'ouvre de l'intérieur de 70 ans
et pour en parler nous sommes avec cielo
homesick et rigaud avocat
constitutionnaliste franco-colombienne
bonsoir selon
trigaux merci d'être avec nous ces
violences pour vous était elle
prévisible
oui bonsoir à tous même si pour
l'invitation et bao les faits en khl à
nier qu'ils pourraient dégénérer les
violences at-elle comment nous avons vu
d'après l'émission que vous venez de
passer
et même si la pression de la vue et par
la pression le gouvernement a dû retirer
cette réforme à fiscale et les mini sera
dû démissionner les mécontentements des
citoyens est si fort que les
manifestants et les manifestations se
révèle de plus en plus nombreuses dans
tous les coins du pays et cela malgré la
forte pression du gouvernement les
chiffres des violations des droits de
l'homme sont est scandaleuse nous
comptons aujourd'hui 31 ans miss id des
jeunes qui manifestaient pacifiquement
et loups apprennent 89 gens portés
disparus
presque un millier d'arrestations
arbitraires 21 victimes d'attaqués
oculaire est à peu près 77,4 découverte
et ceux des victimes des violences
sexuelles et sans compter et tous les
arrestations et arbitraire qui se
contentent dans tous les pays et nous
vivons ces moments des moments de grande
tension dans la juge dans la journée et
de nuit de véritable horreur et les
présidents a décidé la militarisation du
pays dont les dernières jours nous
assistons à des scènes d'horreur en
direct à travers les réseaux sociaux
nous savons la presle impression qu et
notamment pendant la nuit
c'est sur les militaires qui commande
dans le pays et que les maires et les
gouverneurs régionaux et non ce ne sont
pas entendues par le gouvernement dont
ces s'appelle est d'arrêter la violence
la brutalité contre les manifestants
comment vous vous expliquer c'est
violent c'est vrai qu'on n'avait pas
l'habitude de voir un pays comme
la colombie avec ces images choquantes
comment les expliquer bâle avait little
à la vérité c'est que les gens sont
vraiment et puis c'est avec un
gouvernement qui a pas de garantie face
à la pandémie
les gens sont en train d'écrire défend
la réforme fiscale qui ont essayé de
passer et a affecté et porter notamment
contre la classe moyenne et les secteurs
les plus vulnérables et qui se voit sans
garantie de la part du gouvernement
alors que et les banques et les grands
événements publics à qui ça fait pendant
la lutte à l'émergence été versé le vécu
ce pour sauver la banque publique pour
les secteurs les plus favorisés et la la
la la la crise aussi grave que les gens
n'ont plus non plus et peur bella de la
pandémie et de risque de contagion est
alors que en traversant les pics dans le
troisième bague à la plus fort de la
pandémie en ce moment est à peu près de
500 morts par jour est néanmoins les
gens n'ont plus peur de perdre leur vie
n'ont plus peur de faire face à la
brutalité de l'état et les forces
militaires et forces de l'ordre puisque
puisqu'elles sont vraiment est
inacceptable et les mesures qui sont
prises par les gouvernements en ce
moment et la brutalité et mentaux et la
répression
initialement ces manifestations c'était
contre le projet de réforme fiscale qui
a pourtant été retiré depuis ça veut
dire que dans le fond ce n'était qu'un
simple prétexte le malaise et est bien
plus profond les mâles esseulés bien
plus profond et ce n'est pas seulement
compte que ces réformes a concoté en
colombie mais aussi contre une réforme
et contrat et pour la santé qui est en
train de céder ses maîtres de ses
maîtres considération du parent aimant
qui est complément est contraire aux
intérêts des travailleurs de la santé et
des citoyens et cette réforme et cette
prothèse cette manifestation se font
aussi contre un gouvernement et qui a
démontré son incapacité pour perfect
pour faire face à la crise a qui ne
devait pas la pandémie un gouvernement
qui a
des graves après les graves accusations
par corruption par violations des droits
de l'homme et un gouvernement qui ne
respecte pas les accords qui ont été
signés avec la guérilla de la sphère et
avec les compromis qui ont été acquis
près de la communauté internationale un
gouvernement qui ne fait rien pour
arrêter l'assassinât des ridelles
sociaux et l'assassinât des gens qui se
sont démobilisés et donc il ya un
véritable crise et en colombie en
expression sociale et à un moment que
l'aï pas vécue dans les dernières sont
sont en colombie et enclenche surtout et
c'est que sous prétexte de la tension
sociale et pays de la crise que nous
vivons et les gouvernements et va passer
un état d'énergie supérieure qui va
permettre éventuellement même d'empêcher
les sélections est envisagé pour l'année
prochaine pour 2021 2022
donc on est essentiel élire un nouveau
président de la république a eu un
congrès la république
on est face à un gouvernement qui jouit
d'une popularité des mois les 33 % et
les anglais le dernier sondage et
démontre que si les sélections se fera
aujourd'hui est celui qui fait la
position en colombie serait le président
conseil moment et on craint vraiment que
c'est tout ça c'est un il ya un intérêt
de la part des gouvernements mais aussi
des deux groupes au match de la loi et
pour empêcher un changement dans le pays
pour empêcher des sélections qui
permettra en virement dans un
gouvernement plus garantie pour les
citoyens
vous parlez des facs sont mes dernières
questions injustement le gouvernement
arguait que des dissidents des farc si
que l'armée de libération nationale
dernière en rébellion du pays ont
précisé des gangs de narcotrafiquants
orchestré ces troubles ce sont des faits
avérés à vridi et la plupart des
manifestations sont pacifiques
mais il est vrai que les médias et les
gouvernements colombien essaye de
démontrer et
c'est panique dans les sens où on est
dépassé par des violences et qui ne
s'est pas avéré bien parce que dans les
manifestations il apparaît on a les
informations qu'il a des centres et des
débris pas marche de la loi et qu'ils
ont intérêt à taire ces climats ddd
paniqué duplice mais mais mais surtout
et il faudrait marquer que dans la
plupart des milliers de citoyens et des
colombiens que ces manifestants
pacifiques pacifiquement dans la rue et
c'est tout la force de l'ordre qui est
des manières d proportionnée et
utilisées pendant l'ère pendant la
journée et aussi dans la nuit qui était
inacceptable et il n'y a pas il n'y a
pas de il n'a pas d'équivalence il n'y a
pas de proportionnalité entre
l'utilisation de la force de notre
public et le désordre au clic et kiki
semaine à part celle pas un coin et dont
certains secteurs aux minoritaires si
vous voulez et on a peut vraiment que
dans cette confusion est celui qui sait
favorise finalement c'est le
gouvernement qui essaye d d d installer
et ses discours de l'inde l'ennemi
interne et pour à travers celui là et
permettra de passer à un état de
concentration des pouvoirs et un et à
l'émergence la plus grave qui va arrêter
va suspendre encore plus les garanties
démocratiques d'un état de droit
merci c'est le racing et origo d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france
la droite plébiscité à madrid aux
élections régionales la présidente
sortante membre du parti populaire
double son score par rapport au dernier
scrutin il y a deux ans selon les
résultats partiels un revers cinglant
pour le parti socialiste du premier
ministre pedro sanchez qui avait brandi
la menace de la droite radicale pour
mobiliser les électeurs cyrielle bout et
[Musique]
madrid reste à droite
selon des résultats quasi définitifs le
parti populaire a remporté 44 % des voix
lors des élections régionales de la
capitale espagnole ce mardi une victoire
pour la présidente sortante de la région
isabelle dias ayuso aujourd'hui un
nouveau chapitre de l'histoire de
l'espagne commence parce qu'aujourd'hui
depuis madrid depuis le kilomètre zéro
nous allons récupérer la fierté le
sentiment d'appartenance la culture de
l'effort et surtout le vivre ensemble
l'unité et la liberté dont l'espagne a
besoin aujourd'hui c'est un nouveau
départ aujourd'hui commence à nouveau
départ un nouveau départ célébrée dans
les rues madrilènes ce mardi soir ce
scrutin particulièrement suivis à
mobiliser la région malgré la pandémie
avec plus de 5 millions d'électeurs aux
urnes
forte de sa stratégie en faveur des
entreprises et contre les restrictions
strictes
isabelle dias ayuso a su convaincre les
gens voulaient vraiment de la stabilité
et c'est une réponse à ce que nous avons
vécu pendant la pandémie avec la
situation de co vide
donc je pense que ce résultat est tout à
fait normal
honnêtement je suis assez heureuse cela
va être très bon pour madrid parce que
tous les endroits vont être ouverts les
entrepreneurs vont pouvoir gagner de
l'argent et continuer à travailler et
cela va être tellement bénéfique pour
nous tous
surtout pour l'économie
[Musique]
honnêtement isabelle diaz iaudio a fait
une grande campagne
je pense que cela va être la meilleure
chose pour madrid nous allons enfin
avoir ce que nous avons toujours voulu
un magret de libre pour tout le monde
ceux qui pensent différemment pour tout
le monde finalement nous sommes super
heureux nous avons fait la fête tout en
gardant à l'esprit les mesures du coc
vide et nous sommes tellement heureux
une véritable douche froide pour la
gauche du chef du gouvernement pedro
sanchez particulièrement investi dans
cette campagne le parti socialiste perd
ainsi 12 députés régionaux
nous allons analyser ce qui s'est passé
évidemment nous ne pensons pas que les
résultats soient bons c'est évident et
nous ne nous attendions pas à cela
c'est aussi vrai nous avions espéré que
ce que nous proposions aurait pu marcher
et se donne a manifestement pas été le
cas et un décès dans sa news dans deux
ans nous nous reverrons lors des
élections je suis sûr qu'au cours de ces
deux années nous nous trouverons notre
vitalité mais montreront nos capacités
et nous analyserons ce que nous devons
réorienter dans ce scrutin le président
du gouvernement espagnol perd un allié
de taille à l'annoncé des résultats
pablos iglesias chef du parti gauche
radicale podemos a annoncé son retrait
de la politique un scrutin local qui a
pourtant des airs de test national en
espagne
à deux ans des prochaines élections
législatives espagnoles cette victoire
de la droite pourrait être décisive pour
l'avenir politique du pays
en israël à présent le chef de
l'opposition mandaté par le président
yvelines pour former un gouvernement
face à l'incapacité de miami netanyahu
de consulter de constituer par dans son
équipe
le président s'est tourné vers yaïr
lapid une manoeuvre qui pourrait mettre
fin à l'ère netanyahu le chef du parti
d'opposition souhaitent former un
gouvernement d'union nationale et
rallier la droite le centre et la gauche
en cas d'échec les citoyens de l'état
hébreu devront retourner aux urnes pour
la cinquième fois en deux ans à côté
justement le président israélien
[Musique]
ceux qui parlent dit mais sur la base
des recommandations que j'ai reçu des
partis de la knesset et conformément à
l'autorité qui m'est accordée en vertu
du paragraphe 9 de la loi fondamentale
sur le gouvernement
je viens de m'entretenir avec le député
de la knesset hier la pipe et de
l'informer que je lui donne le mandat de
former un gouvernement nicolo et ammann
date mais vouera chez la roma nous
sommes pris dans un labyrinthe depuis
longtemps pour ne pas dire une crise
politique mais nous ne devons pas
permettre à ces difficultés d'entamer
notre foi dans le fait que nous sommes
sur la bonne voie et que nous pouvons
continuer à construire la souveraineté
du peuple israélien
ribbon août à albi restez avec nous dans
quelques instants nous parlerons de la
crise sanitaire en france l'épidémie
ralentit l'entente à deux semaines de la
prochaine étape de déconfinement est
alors qu'hier les députés ont donné leur
feu vert un premier feu vert pour le
passé ni terre
les grands rassemblements une mesure qui
divise ce sera l'objet de notre face à
face
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la gt pour tous ce que ça rapporte aux
enfants c'est une confiance confiance en
soi ils ont soif d'apprendre et izm la
connaissance mais quelque chose les
blocs aussi dans l'apprentissage à
l'école les enfants de l'ambition ils
veulent à accéder à des groupes aussi
veulent s'évader du quartier qu'est ce
qui ne fonctionne pas dans
l'apprentissage à l'école les
professeurs des écoles fonds nécessaires
mais je rencontre des instituteurs des
institutrices en ce1 ce2 il ya des
enfants qui ont vraiment encore du mal à
lire et écrire
et c'est pénalisant pour l'enfant pour
la famille on oublie les parents qui
sont responsables du foyer est temps que
les parents ne maîtrise et ne parlent
pas le français à la maison basse année
difficile
[Musique]
et
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi qui dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
déception l'univers uniforme c'est quand
même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
les gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas l'oublié
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct
il y a quand même la liberté je vous
remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
bienvenue à novossibirsk nous sommes au
bord de la volga le plus long fleuve
d'europe
nous sommes à chez vox harry
allons faire connaissance
vous avez choisi le jour à bagdad alors
je suis arrivé en 2005 pour étudier
dernière fois celle en profiter en 2011
le monde manque pas un petit peu non ah
oui et c'est tous les fromages tous les
soucis sont toutes les les croissants la
pâtisserie traits de caractère des
russes qui te plaît l'amitié les gens
les gens très stylée les français ne le
savent pas je ne pensais jamais de ma
vie faire la plonge et autonomie vous
pouvez me souhaiter bon courage
à très bientôt sur un terreau france
[Musique]
21h bonsoir merci nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'émission tout de
suite voici les titres de l'actualité de
ce mercredi 5 mai la crise sanitaire
plus aucun département dessus du seuil
des 400 mille 400 cas pour 100000
habitants seuil fixé par emmanuel macron
pour activer des mesures de frein
d'urgence d'un situation épidémique
s'améliore doucement mais les hôpitaux
restent surchargé premier feu vert des
députés ou pas sanitaire malgré de vives
réticences ou nous conte se passe au
s'allonger de notre face à face une
honte absolue la colère de donald trump
après la décision du conseil de
surveillance de facebook de le bannir
définitivement de la plateforme son
compte avait été suspendu après une
publication qui remettait en cause
l'élection de
résultat de l'élection présidentielle
pour tenter de contrer le géant du web
le meilleur des relances aujourd'hui son
propre site
[Musique]
toujours aux états unis derek chauvine
veut faire annuler le verdict qu'il a
condamné ce policier reconnu coupable
d'avoir tué de change floyd l'année
dernière a déposé une requête
aujourd'hui ils remettent en cause
l'impartialité du jury
[Musique]
la situation sanitaire en france est un
énième conseil ne défend ce matin à deux
semaines de la prochaine étape du
déconfinement les indicateurs épidémique
s'améliore lentement mais les hôpitaux
restent surchargé si un peu moins de 16
millions et demi de français ont reçu
une première dose de vaccin le porte
parole du gouvernement dit ne pas
vouloir faire de leçon de morale aux
personnes s'étant fait vacciner alors
qu'elles n'y étaient pas autorisés
gabriella talent qui continue d'appeler
à la vigilance
si l'europe et de l'épidémie s'accélère
il reste toujours plus lent qu'au mois
de novembre après le deuxième
confinement notre hôpital et nos
services de réanimation sont toujours
extrêmement sollicités et je veux une
nouvelle fois rendre hommage à toutes
les femmes à tous les hommes qui sont
engagés investi mobilisés aujourd'hui à
l'hôpital pour continuer à accueillir et
à soigner des patients est une étape
importante dans la lutte anti qu'ovide
les députés donnent leur premier feu
vert pour le passé ni terre dans les
grands rassemblements
une disposition toujours très contestée
notamment par l'opposition qui craint
une augmentation des inégalités est
détaillé avec médiers ski fis validé ce
mardi soir par les députés de la
commission des lois le pass sanitaire
reste au coeur des débats et certains
élus ils sont encore farouchement
opposés un projet polémique qui a reçu
l'aval du conseil scientifique et qui
devrait s'appliquer de manière
temporaire et exceptionnelle notamment
pour les rassemblements de plus de 1000
personnes
un qr code intégré à son attestation de
vaccination a scanné ensuite sur
l'application tout senti qu vide
voilà en quoi consiste le certificat
vaccinale appelé à se développer dans
l'hexagone une première étape dans
l'instauration de ce passeport numérique
qui fait suite au feu vert du parlement
européen
fin avril le pass sanitaire utilisé de
manière temporaire et exceptionnelle
peut permettre à la population une forme
de retour à la vie normale en minimisant
les risques de contamination par le
virus sarr skov de ce pass sanitaire
sera le sésame pour accéder aux
événements sportifs festifs mais aussi
culturelles comme l'a dernièrement
rappelé emmanuel mac
font en revanche pas de dispositions
prévues pour les bars et les restaurants
cet outil numérique a pour but
d'empêcher toute fraude en garantissant
la fiabilité des attestations un procédé
toutefois loin de faire l'unanimité au
sein de l'opposition qui redoute un
accroissement des inégalités entre les
vaccinés et les autres il n'y aura pas
de limites dont la discrimination
le texte n'est pas clair on ne fait pas
de distinguo entre rassemblement
intérieur ou extérieur
ça ressemble à une discrimination pour
moi c'est un précédent
outre les risques de stigmatisation
qu'il soulève se passe à l'inconvénient
de ne pas reconnaître tous les vaccins
seuls sont concernés pour l'instant les
sérums autorisé par lieu à savoir ceux
de pfizer biotech astrazeneca moderna et
johnson johnson
en attendant l'examen du texte de ce
projet de loi se poursuit en commission
ce jeudi avant son passage dans
l'hémicycle lundi prochain
alors ouvrons contre se passe sanitaire
c'est l'objet de notre face à face
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
pierre jeantet remaniant radiologue
président de l'union régionale des
professionnels de santé libéraux de la
région auvergne rhône-alpes bonsoir jean
pierre interne amiens merci d'être avec
nous à vos côté florian philippot
président des patriotes bonsoir florian
philippot merci d'être avec nous alors
ce premier feu vert des députés une
bonne nouvelle plus tôt pour vous ou
jean-pierre tard gagnant je pense que
c'est une bonne nouvelle mais je
voudrais simplement replacer le débat
est ce qu'il ya un seul français qui
s'est pas fait vacciner on va dire
contre le dtpolio il ya onze vaccins
obligatoires en france
si la santé a fait des progrès dans
point de vue population c'est pas
tellement accru de très humble c'est pas
grave on va dire ou nouveaux traitements
mais c'est essentiellement via deux
cause l'hygiène et la deuxième cause
c'est la vaccination à partir de là on a
jubilé le choléra on a jugulé la polio
mais dites moi je suis d'une génération
je suis plus âgées où j'avais des
copains qui avait des séquelles de
policiers on en voit plus maintenant
elle en tant que médecin jean voit
quasiment plus aux joies des gens qui
sont de ma génération la variole a été
éradiquée donc le débat de dire que l'on
crée une discrimination entre ceux qui
sont vaccinées ou pas je dirais ça ne
pose aucun problème vous ne pouvez pas
vous inscrire dans la fonction publique
hospitalière
si vous n'êtes pas vacciné contre
l'hépatite b c'est la loi
vous ne pouvez pas aller en guyane si
vous n'avez pas un certificat de fièvre
jour de vaccination
florian philippot vous je sais que vous
n'êtes pas des mêmes avis on arrive à ce
que vous redoutiez mais c'est vrai que
le docteur un terme à nyon vient
d'apporter quand même des éléments assez
implacable vous êtes d'accord un petit
peu ou pas du tout non mais je suis pas
du tout d'accord si vous voulez choses
l'une soit le vaccin que les 19 et
obligatoire il fallait le dire il
fallait pas dire linverse et macron fin
novembre un dinar est justement précisé
que c'était la liberté vaccinale et s'il
n'est pas obligatoire alors on ne peut
pas mettre en place d'outils qui moi
aussi j'ai fait le fiel rejoint parce
que je suis en guyane
on va pas en guyane où dans 20 pays
africains où ils seraient également
demandées
tous les quatre matins en revanche les
éléments qui sont concernés par ce pass
solitaire c'est un précédent c'est une
première c'est pour aujourd'hui aller
dans un rassemblement de plus de mille
personnes ce sera des festivals je
serais allé au stade ce sera un meeting
politique ce sera un une fois une
exposition et puis hier cédric au le
secrétaire d'état au numérique a dit ça
sera aussi dans les salles de cinéma qui
ont plus de 1000 spectateurs
il a précisé ce sera aussi dans les
restaurants que plus de mille couverts
et on voit bien que on ouvre une boîte
de pandore ou en fait on crée selon
l'état de santé de florian philippot
qu'est ce qui nous dérange le plus parce
que vous dites vous dites voilà dans ce
cas il fallait rendre obligatoire la
vaccination des débuts c'est
l'hypocrisie ou ont finalement c'est la
discrimination que cela entraînerait
selon vous ben c'est très hypocrite
parce que c'est une manière de rendre
obligatoire sans le dire et deuxièmement
et moi je suis contre l'obligation
vaccinale je précise je suis pour la
liberté vaccinale et deuxièmement c'est
un précédent tir ils ont créé une
ségrégation sanitaire selon le son
statut sérologique
selon son choix thérapeutiques selon son
choix de l'acsi nation on met le doigt
dans un engrenage extrêmement dangereux
parce que demain une fois qu'on aura
installé ces outils les qr codes
l'application numérique et de ça qui
nous dit qu'on va pas y ajouter d'autres
vaccins d'autres choix thérapeutiques
d'autres pathologies qui seront
discriminante pour avoir le droit
d'aller dans telle ou telle lieux ou de
pratiquer telle ou telle activité ou de
pouvoir avoir une telle ou telle prêts
bancaires ou travail ça on entre on
ouvre une boîte de pandore ont créé en
dehors de tout débat éthique et moral
je crois que c'est un vrai problème
moral éthique cette affaire on crée un
précédent qui va nous jamais les
probablement quelque chose d extrêmement
inquiétant est d'ailleurs plusieurs pays
ne s'y sont pas trompés et ils ont
interdit le passeport qualités à
commencer par les états unis
pierre-jean tamagnan quand vous entendez
ces arguments vous y êtes sensibles et
moi je suis obligé de constater que
cette pandémie tue encore 300 personnes
par jour en france que nos systèmes de
ranimation sont en légère décrue mais en
restant saturation et on a alors gelé
très friable
la chance d'avoir un variant anglais en
france parce que si on avait demain le
variant brésilien ou sud-africain
là c'est une panique totale donc je
crois que si on veut on va dire rendre
une liberté aux gens de se déplacer
d'aller voir leur famille d'aller voir
les restaurants ça passe par un certain
nombre de contraintes je crois qu'il
faut je dirai tout le monde est bien
d'accord peut-être que le pass de
vaccination c'est pas forcément le bon
terme je défends moi un carnet de
vaccination électronique pour chaque
pression soit citoyen et responsable des
zags et puis quand on est tous dans la
rue devant un feu rouge
on respecte leur on peut être content ou
les limitations de vitesse que l'on veut
mais dans tous les cas quelqu'un de
sensé pas s'arrêter au feu rouge
donc la possibilité d'avoir un qr code
alors avec des limites c'est à dire que
si jamais vous avez effectivement
quelqu'un qui est enregistrée il faut
qu'à la fin de cet événement ça s'efface
ces données mais c'est le meilleur moyen
pour protéger la population
c'est indispensable si on veut revenir
on a tous marre les soignants en
particulier parce qu'on voit la mort et
on ne sait pas forcément toujours bien
l'accepter parce que quand ça de ça
devient répétitif
rappelez-vous au début de la première
pandémie c'était on va dire un égrenage
de nombre de gens maintenant ça n'émeut
personne vous voyez des scènes en inde
on brûle mais des milliers de personnes
il ya plus d'oxygène en ainsi demain ça
nous arrive alors il ya un autre
problème si vous voulez c'est que ce
passeport vaccinale va nous permettre on
va dire d'avoir ce carnet de vaccination
électronique que je souhaite ardemment
c'est que ça nous permet de savoir
je dirais chaque personne c'est qu'elle
à 7,25 on peut donc être libre après
d'aller parce que le risque de
contaminer est faible et on a un autre
souci c'est le défaut qu'on peut
rencontrer proment sur la vaccination
avec les vaccins à adénovirus ou le
danemark par exemple sopo d'astrazeneca
s'oppose à johnson and johnson
or la campagne vaccinale française
repose à presque 30 2 33% sur ces deux
vaccins
donc il ya un vrai risque on va tarder à
vacciner la population
il ya toujours des gens il faut
respecter le libre à vis des gens qui
seront contents n'y peut rien contre
lourdement
2 effectivement de faire en sorte de ne
pas contaminer les autres parce que
quand on voit les scènes dans la rue
sans masque ça laisse un peu raide en
tout cas les français sont plutôt court
à regarder ce sondage harris interactive
ou lci l'instauration de cet outil pour
accéder donc à ces grands événements
recueille le soutien quand même 67% de
la population
alors ce n'est qu'un sondage mais
florian philippot vous êtes étonné parce
que c'est vrai qu'on parlait bien il ya
quelques mois de ce scepticisme très
français c'est vrai qu'on sent qu'on n'a
plus le choix et que les français
veulent avant tout retrouver une vie
normale vous comprenez justement ce
sondage
non mais je suis inquiet parce qu'un
chantage de la peur évident si vous
voulez on a fait croire aux gens qu'ils
façon si vous voulez retrouver leur
liberté c'était au bout de la seringue
ou c'était au bout du test pcr et en
fait on fait de la liberté ce qui
devrait être un absolu ce qui est dans
notre devise d'ailleurs un au fronton de
nos mairies et c'est même le premier mot
on en fait une variable d'ajustement
sanitaire en jouant sur la peur menés
par ayant des sites et le variant sud
africain bien s'il vous arrive ça va
être terrible je finirai qu'il a
représenté un moment 60% des
contaminations en moselle département
que je connais bien j'y suis élu on nous
a dit ça va être la catastrophe absolue
il a régressé n'a pas eu le confinement
particulier en modèle ça il a réglé ses
et il n'y a pas eu la catastrophe ou
d'annoncés donc si vous voulez donc on
voit bien qu'il ya une volonté de
pousser les gens vers ce truc qui est
pour moi gravissime c'est une société
qui bascule civilisation qui bascule où
on pourra donner des droits
supplémentaires aux gens selon leur état
de santé selon leur choix thérapeutiques
et je suis désolé ça n'est pas
compatible avec le l'idée que je me fais
de l'homme de la dignité et de nos
valeurs les plus sacrées et et
deuxièmement il ya des contre-exemples
might magic mouse trop puisque les
etats-unis ont refusé ont interdit ce
pass sanitaire au nom du secret médical
qui doit être respectée or là il sera
bafouée au nom des grandes libertés
il est même en floride pénalisé par une
amende de 5000 dollars si jamais été
mise en place et je signale que début
mars le texas mississippi où d'autres
états américains ont tous rouvert ont
dit on arrête même le masque obligatoire
à extérieur etc et bart hayden et
d'autres avec certains médecins leur
promettez l'apocalypse aujourd'hui vous
regardez les classes sont effondrés
il n'y a pas du tout lui au contraire
l'apocalypse annoncée donc sans lui dire
aux français arrêtez de vous faire avoir
par ce discours de chantage
il va vous mener aujourd'hui on vous dit
les événements de plus de 1000 personnes
il ya trois semaines on vous disais plus
de 5000 1 et demain on vous dira
n'importe quel restaurant ou n'importe
quel cinéma c'est une évidence
la mécanique de cette affaire est
toujours la même d'autant qu'en france
nous avons la malchance d'avoir l'union
européenne qui poussent derrière
depuis longtemps en réalité parce que ce
projet dans les cartons sont offerts
depuis longtemps et est que nous sommes
extrêmement soumis hasna me signale
qu'en suisse il y aura un référendum le
13 juin sur la loi qu'ovide un
référendum d'initiative citoyenne qui
notamment cette loi comme il contient le
pass italie terre ou pas et ce sera aux
suisses de décider j'aimerais que les
français eux aussi décider ce qu'il a
vraiment vous parler de l'union
européenne je vous invite tous les deux
à rester avec moi parce qu'on va aller
voir ce qui se passe en allemagne
puisque l'allemagne est à s'oublier
justement les règles pour les personnes
vaccinées elle a décidé de lever les
restrictions de circulation pour ceux
qui ont été immunisés soit parce qu'ils
sont vaccinés soit parce qu'elles ont
déjà ulcos vie 19 cette décision
entérinée avant vendredi par les deux
chambres est applicable à partir de
samedi pour en parler avant de retrouver
nos invités nous retrouvons peter oliver
correspondant d'ayrté à berlin bonsoir
peter oliver merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france l'allemagne qui
assouplit ses règles mais on les sent
tout de même restaurants et hôtels
fermés un faux pas non plus plaisanter
comment est accueillie cette décision
outre rhin ce que ça suscite des débats
comme on les entend avec nos deux
invités ou au sein des différentes
régions par exemple
ayasse team cela dépend d'où l'on se
trouve en allemagne
si vos droits vont peut-être renforcer
les restrictions vont être à soutenir si
vous avez déjà été vaccinées si vous
pouvez prouver que vous avez des
anticorps contre lacko bild c'est une
très bonne nouvelle si vous habitez
étant les états allemands commençant par
b est telle que le brandebourg brême etc
car ils ont déclaré tout comme la
bavière qu'il souhaitait assouplir les
restrictions pour les personnes déjà
vaccinées
la ministre de la justice allemand a
déclaré que ces personnes ne faisait
qu'un risque minimal de contracter cette
maladie et clis j'irai donc signé pas
d'assouplissement de violer leurs droits
constitutionnels
certains états ne souhaite pas assouplir
les règles c'est un débat un coup on ne
sait pas si le bundestag va adultes et
la mesure est comme vous l'avait dit il
ya un changement pour est entrée en
vigueur des recettes mais en tout cas
d'ici à la fin du mois le 27
la raison de cet assouplissement est une
question de chiffres les chiffres
baissent jeu taux de contamination
diminue c'est à dire dont trois aux
mains de personnes contractent lakovic
et le nombre de lits occupés dans les
unités de soins intensifs sont également
en baisse seuls leurs chiffres qui
impacte c'est le nombre des factions et
en allemagne
huit cent mille personnes ont reçu doses
de vaccin la première dose de vaccin au
cours des 24 dernières
plus de 150 personnes reçues leur
seconde dose au cours des 24 dernières
heures 9 % de la population a reçu un
vaccin complet c'est un club encore très
fermé dont les effectifs augmentent et
voilà pourquoi les législateurs pense
qu'on peut assouplir les restrictions
pour les personnes qui ont été déjà été
vaccinées
peter la décision prise cette semaine
donne aussi aux vacciner le droit de se
réunir plus nombreux en famille est ce
que ce n'est pas discriminant
socialement comment est accueillie aussi
cette mesure dans le pays ils ont un
droit finalement pour faire la fête
les aspects de cette position c'est
qu'il s'agirait de mettre un terme aux
restrictions tout contact donc si vous
avez été vaccinées ainsi que vos amis
vous pouvez vous rassemblez quel que
soit votre ombre est effectivement faire
la fête
restrictions vont également être levé
par exemple oeuvre pour aller chez le
coiffeur ou dans certaines boutiques
donnée essentielle qui avait été fermé
si vous avez été vaccinées vous avez un
pass liberté en quelque sorte et la
ministre de la justice a dit qu'il
serait potentiellement non
constitutionnels d'empêcher ces
personnes présentant à ce que minimum de
vivre leur vie habituel beaucoup
d'autres gens prennent la parole et 10
ouvrir le pays pour certaines personnes
vaccinées serait anticonstitutionnelle a
car cela irait à l'encontre du droit à
un traitement égal donc il ya vraiment
un ce débat sur le bien-fondé ou
justice de cette décision est en tout
cas potes les trouvera que vous
obtiendrez défendre son vote de la
région et à lutter pour ceux qui n'ont
pas reçu la vaccination en tout cas le
confinement devrait courir jusqu'à la
fin du mois au moins et pourrait même
continuer pourrait y avoir alors une
réouverture spontanée et rapide pour les
personnes vaccinées
merci peter oliver correspondant verte
et à berlin et on va retrouver nos deux
invités un pierre jeantet damian et
florian philippot sur l'opportunité de
se passer ni terre ou non jean-pierre
terme à nyon évidemment en tant que
médecin vous nous dites c'est très bien
mais n'est ce pas un petit peu injuste
quand même de priver les gens finalement
de leur liberté à partir du moment où
tout le monde en france na n'est pas en
mesure de pouvoir se faire vacciner
aujourd'hui parce qu'il ya une pénurie
de vaccins alors je pense qu'il faut
peut-être pas forcément poser la
question comme ça pour préciser bien les
situations en moselle c'est 35% le virus
sud africain ce qui a obligé la haute
autorité de santé a changé la stratégie
v la stratégie va nationale non ça n'est
jamais monté à 30 60 % on sait rester à
35 37 % maximum voulu révéler les
chiffres non mais j'ai les chiffres sous
le nez je vous le rassure et c'est pour
ça qu'ils ont changé la vaccination ils
sont basculées sur modern art c'est le
seul stratégie qu'on peut mettre pour
éteindre un incendie de manière à avoir
un arn messagers vaccin
non mais parce que je dirais on a réagi
en mettant un vaccin qui est beaucoup
plus efficace alors que l'astra zurich
avec rld n'aura pas le sujet et si aux
états unis ça je dirais bien marché
c'est parce que ils ont de la chance les
américains c'est que contrairement à la
france où ça a été un peu laborieux leur
politique vaccinale francon et puis dire
ils ont beaucoup plus de personnes
vaccinées ce qui permet on va dire
d'obtenir une efficacité alors sur la
perte de chance ou sur la discrimination
je crois qu'il faut pas le voir dans cet
angle là je crois qu'il faut offrir à
tous les français possible je dirais y
compris en déplaçant des cars est ce que
l'on fait dans notre région de manière à
pouvoir vacciner les gens si vous voulez
le plus rapidement aussi après il y aura
toujours des gens qui sont contre
et ça vous pouvez en est en démocratie
il faut respecter mais je pense que la
seule solution on va dire c'est vraiment
d'avoir une vaccination est de permettre
aux gens à partir du monstre ou vacciner
qu'on se retrouve pas avec le fait qu'on
garde des mesures alors sur le sur ce
qu'ils appellent un passé moi qui n'est
pas le bon terme mais je préférerais un
carnet qui permettrait d'avoir des
réelles données perso sur son téléphone
et que l'on peut disposer quand on va
voir son médecin ou service des urgences
il ya une chose qui à mon avis moi me
pose un problème c'est mettre dans le
même sac
si vous voulez la vaccination qui est
l'efficacité 2 le fait des tests le test
pcr même de 72 heures je dirais que
c'est bien mais pendant 72 heures vous
pouvez vous être contaminé donc le seul
facteur de juge il y en a deux c'est le
masque que l'on doit porter en
permanence et la vaccination
et ça ça va nous permettre de revivre et
d'avoir une vie sociale
quand on est en société c'est pas
l'adéquation de liberté individuelle
on doit faire un choix et c'est vrai que
tout le monde respecte la circulation
que feu rouge
tous les enfants sont vaccinés c'est
comme ça je veux dire si vous voulez
sauver on va dire une population ne vous
avais pas le choix que florian philippot
bout faire un niveau non mais c'est une
vraie question c'est finalement on
laisse de côté l'individualité pour le
collectif parce que là pour le coup il
ya une question de santé publique majeur
à bakel vie vous nous promettez étant du
virus
malheureusement non à vous messieurs
vous nous avez montré un masque
d'ailleurs un sacré masse qui vous nous
dites qu'une vacciner tous sous couvert
code
tous souhaitent passer ses vacances je
suis devant vous la tendance est plus
une vie est par ailleurs sur le texas
d'une trompe l'oeil quand ils ont ouvert
il y avait 9 % de double vacciner et
enfin à vue il avait 23 % donc c'est pas
le facteur explicatif
c'est simplement mesure de la place
c'est le premier état quasiment dans la
taille ils sont pas très serré au texas
areva je pense que c'est ça la voilà en
corée du sud où il ya une densité
gigantesque on aurait dû avoir
énormément de morts il y en a beaucoup
moins
la petite conduit encore et encore je
suis un geek au vide
ils ont bien sûr parce qu'ils ont tracé
les gens avec un système très
particulière elle permettait de remonter
toujours une bonne excuse
vous avez toujours une excuse je vais
vous dire monsieur quand on a quand on a
prêté le serment d'hippocrate comme vous
avez dû le faire et qu'on accepte le
différencier les gens selon leur état de
santé leur donner des droits ou pas si
si ou leur choix avec nous nos ou leur
choix thérapeutique on accepte cet
engrenage pour de sombres raisons qui
m'échappent mais on creusera la faire et
parce que les histoires de pognon
gigantesque derrière c'est pas de faire
là évidemment et le conflit d'intérêts
et je lui ai proposé cette affaire alors
je me dis qu'on n'est plus digne du
serment d'hippocrate voilà moi je dis
aux français ne rentrait pas dans cette
logique ne mettait pas votre liberté en
qr code ne m'accepte et pas ces fous qui
veulent vous imposer une vie sous masque
ou vaccins ce qr code sous plexiglas etc
lisez le rapport du défenseur des droits
est sorti hier son la manière dont tu
m'a traité pour les raisons que vous
évoquez nos anciens on les a traités
comme des chiens
on les a laissé crever parce qu'il y
avait des médecins plateaux télé qui
disent être il faut les éloigner faut
les laisser seuls dans leur chambre et
star on les a laissé crever comme une
civilisation n'aurais jamais dû le faire
et même mourir seul sans voir leurs
proches
n'acceptez pas ça fait pression pour que
enfin ils autorisent les traitements une
laisse les médecins à prescrire fait
pression et fait pression par l'outil
qu'ils avaient de consommateurs
boycotter les les enseignes et les
événements qui demanderont se passe un
état vous savez il perd 10% leur chiffre
d'affaires alors eux mêmes sur notre
fleuron pour tout le gouvernement et on
gagnera
merci à tous les deux est évidemment de
jeu ces propos n'engagent que vous
florian philippot bien évidemment
promeut pas le non port de masques ici
en tout cas tous les avis sont entendus
sur arte france merci pierre jeantet
remaniant et merci à dans quelques
instants rester avec nous direction les
états unis où la colère de donald trump
banni définitivement de facebook le
milliardaire répliqué dans sa propre
plateforme et puis nous parlons de
derek robin le policier condamné pour le
meurtre de john jay dépose une requête
en annulation de son procès
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
en avril aura lieu le 60e anniversaire
du vol de youri gagarine en ayant eu la
chance de m'entraîner avec nos collègues
russes j'ai vraiment plongé dans une
atmosphère où j'ai vécu auprès de méroé
gagarine était présent à chaque point de
bâtiments de salles de sport de place de
la cité des étoiles moi je crois
beaucoup dans la diplomatie scientifique
et quand vous parlez de la coopération
scientifique sur la station bihan ou la
station spatiale internationale
c'est une forme de diplomatie on a très
peu d'objets aujourd'hui qui peuvent
être des outils diplomatiques aussi aux
six ans
[Musique]
notre société vit un moment très
important dans la lutte contre les
violences de l'intimé violence de la
maison il y à chaque année 300 mille
personnes victimes de violences
sexuelles
70% des plaintes classées sans suite et
un nombre de condamnations
d'ailleurs en baisse mais autour de 1000
condamnation par an nous devons
progresser de deux manières la première
c'est par la loi et ensuite progresser
parce que nous appelons des pratiques
professionnelles protectrice la justice
à sa part dans cette impunité comment
souhaitez vous la faire évoluer
nous devons être concret pour que la
protection ne soit pas un mot mais une
réalité
[Musique]
ce sont les trafics de drogue d'une
certaine façon qui sont peut-être les
meilleurs adeptes de la mondialisation
c'est à dire que ils ont inventé les
routes de la drogue bien avant que les
entreprises ne découvrent les bienfaits
de la mondialisation on ne visualise pas
à quel point ça peut être compliqué de
se retrouver avec dans son garage une
montagne de billets de banque comme ça
il faut en faire quelque chose de
l'argent sale devient très rapidement et
très facilement en gris et puis blanc il
suffit de passer par quelques sociétés
écrans
mais à côté de ça vous avez tout un
réseau de banques qui sont beaucoup plus
ouverte au cash à l'époque de la crise
de 2008 vous dit même que les banques
qui ont été beaucoup moins regardante
sur la provenance de cet argent qui
arrivaient pour renflouer les caisses ça
a été même dire nations unies on a
constaté que plusieurs dizaines de
milliards issus du trafic de stupéfiants
ont été absorbés par un certain nombre
de banques aux états unis qui d'ailleurs
ont été poursuivis en justice et ont
payé des amendes en conséquence
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
21h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct sur
rt france si vous nous rejoignez aux
états unis donald trump définitivement
bannis de facebook décision cet
après-midi de conseil de surveillance du
réseau social une honte absolue selon
les mots de l'ancien président évincé le
plusieurs plateformes numériques depuis
janvier les incidents du capitole à
washington
le républicain ouvert un blog pour
continuer à s'exprimer sur internet
de son côté facebook justifie sa
décision une personne devrait-elle
monter ou descendre c'est une personne
puissant c'est important je comprends la
tension et le spectacle qui l'entourent
car c'est important
le mal qui peut provenir du retour de
trump sur la plateforme est immense
alors bien sûr c'est un spectacle
cependant le conseil de surveillance ne
va pas réactiver facebook demain quoi
qu'il fasse il n'a pas le pouvoir de
réactiver facebook
il n'a pas le pouvoir de tenir l'entité
responsable envers ses utilisateurs du
monde entier
ce n'est tout simplement pas le cas ce
n'est pas une cour suprême et pour en
parler nous sommes avec douglas l'est y
ait ce professeur de droit spécialiste
de sciences politiques américaines
bonsoir des glaciers
merci d'être avec nous la décision de
facebook est elle justifiée selon vous
oui les événements de 6 juillet son sens
choquant et dangereux et c'est le
puissance de ses plateformes comme
facebook qui a donné en dotant de la
capacité de mobiliser les gens qu'ils
ont attaqué le capital et ses salles
événement déclencheur à ce que pendant
quatre ans facebook twitter est lui a
laissé le plafond à ses discours et
après le 6 janvier
tout a changé et maintenant c'est au
bannissement permanente
c'est une sim que dans le train mais
plus incapable de augmenter son ne
soutiennent ça montre tout de même de
glace y est le poids de ces de ces
géants d'internet qui a finalement
décidé de fermer la bouche de quelqu'un
ou quelqu'un d'autre en fonction de
leurs croyances finalement puisque ce ne
sont pas des juges nommés à et et et
c'est vrai il y en danger la démocratie
quand vous avez les monopoles dans le
domaine qui décide sans aucune
réglementation ce qui se passe tout le
monde utilise maintenant c'est plate
forme et ils sont énormes puissante et
je m'en doute que qu'en grèce veut
réglementer en dépit des efforts comme
répétition de commencer un procès de on
ne sait pas à quoi faire avec
les gars fin et bien sûr dans nos trente
était une personnalité puissante mais un
joueur et il va décliner et facebook et
à boé gougaud étude de puissance de
mycroft et ses géants d'internet semble
maintenant sans aucune réglementation
lorsque les télévisions et les radios
sont bien de réglementer donc il faut
faire quelque chose
c'est une décision clairement qui est
synonyme d'affaiblissement aujourd'hui
pour donald trump
oui il a annoncé la création de son
propre plate fin et ça louis permis de
communiquer avec sa base c'est à dire
garder des 60 70 millions de votre
républicaine qui aime bien mais oui ça
va diminuer son puissance de augmenter
ces chiffres parce qu'avant sur twitter
tout le monde peuvent consulter ses
truies maintenant selon la légende qui
donne une souscription à un abonnement à
sa plateforme or la capacité est donc le
grand public n'aura pas barrage et avec
ces messages comme avant ça
affaiblissent mais on va voir dans les
deux prochaines années parce que louis
continue à diriger le jeu de parti
républicain il est le plus puissante et
le parti républicain est toujours le
petit hudson ce qui frappe finalement
comme il s'agit d'une entité privée
c'est que d'un entretien même pas de
recours il est banni un point c'est tout
ce n'est pas comme contient une décision
de justice c'est qu'on peut faire appel
non exactement et c'est une société
privée
tout le monde oublie que ce sont des des
sociétés privées parce que habitude l
audiovisuel qui normalement casse dans
les ondes qui sont ré
les montées par le gouvernement mais ici
sur ces plateformes c'est géant
ils ont joué un enjeu se présenter en
tant que société privée prendre service
public et est le signe pour eux qui
soutiennent santé et faute d'accord n'a
pas de recours en justice
qu'on soit une telle bannissement
aujourd'hui risque de cette décision à
ce qu'elles ne risquent pas justement
d'entretenir l'idée d'un acharnement sur
l'ancien président des états unis
oui peut être
ce qui est certain c'est la société
produisez et les grandes sociétés aussi
donc il y à eux qui aiment 30 et le kit
haïssent et l'acharnement oui c'est un
bon mot pour décrire le l'attitude des
deux parties mais la bataille n'est pas
finie
si on a pas que commencer certains noms
connaissant donald trump peut-être pas
de glaciers se propose de rester avec
nous pour continuer à commenter
l'actualité américaine puisque joe biden
a augmenté le plafond national de
réfugiés admis aux états unis alors que
donald trump avait fixé je vous le
rappelle un ce taux à 15 milles pendant
son mandat chiffre historiquement bas à
la surprise générale joe biden avait
décidé de conserver ce seuil il est
finalement revenu sur cette décision
après de nombreuses critiques les
détails d'amaya de son blé avant de
retrouver notre invité la rupture avec
donald trump se fait de plus en plus
nette aux états unis joe biden a annoncé
ce lundi qu'il augmenterait le nombre de
réfugiés est admis aux états unis ue à
soixante deux mille cinq cents par an un
plafond qui avait été baissé à 15000
pendant la mandature de donald trump et
que le nouveau président démocrate avait
choisi de maintenir malgré ses promesses
électorales
soulevant la colère dans son propre camp
complètement et totalement inacceptable
by john a promis d'accueillir les
immigrants et les gens de voter pour lui
sur la base de cette promesse soutenir
les politiques xénophobes et racistes de
l'administration trump y compris le
plafond de réfugiés historiquement bas
et
grïngo les est tout simplement
inacceptable tenez votre promesse
face aux nombreuses critiques joe biden
revient sur cette décision et annonce
vouloir travailler sur les dégâts commis
par son prédécesseur en nouveau plafond
national plus hypothétique que réaliste
du fait de la reconstruction du
programme d'admission des réfugiés la
décision est malgré tout bien accueillis
par de nombreuses associations
nous ne serons pas en mesure d'atteindre
62500 et probablement même pas la moitié
de ce nombre cette année mais c'est un
signal important aux réfugiés et au
reste du monde qui prouve que nous
reconstruisons notre programme que nous
sommes motivés pour atteindre un nombre
plus élevé mieux approprié un pays aussi
grand
aussi puissant et aussi accueillants que
le nôtre ce taux devrait augmenter
sensiblement en 2022 avec un seuil fixé
à 125 mille réfugiés par joe biden là
encore l'objectif sera difficile à
atteindre selon le président lui-même un
programme ambitieux qui fait partie de
l'adn des états unis selon le chef de la
diplomatie anthony blinken qui s'occupe
de sélectionner les réfugiés les plus
vulnérables dans les camps de l'onu on
retrouve à douglas ayed qui est toujours
avec nous professeurs de droit
spécialiste de sciences politiques
américaines clairement douglas yates joe
biden a cédé on l'a vu à la pression de
l'ailé gauche de son camp exactement le
réseau pour la can il a cédé à cette
pression et qu'il a besoin des votes
dans le congrès au facisme législation
le bit insfrastructures mais je crois
pas qu'il va qu'il n'a réussi toutes les
formes d immigration qui l'a promis mais
ça il en fera un peu de vie rendent à la
gauche parce qu'il a besoin d toutes les
autres petites le monde dont le sénat où
les démocrates joue avec un seul
bonhomme majorité clairement cette
cacophonie sur ce sujet c'est sa
première erreur vis-à-vis de son
l'électorat noël il avait un regard
le problème dans la communication lasser
il a avancé son programme sans consulter
les potentiels critique et peut-être
maintenant établir un bon lien de
communication avec les députés minorités
et pro réfugiés mais c'était un gars de
communication plutôt que politique
il a exposé son des yeux de limiter pour
l'instant elle l'entrée de nouvelles
dans les états unis en cause de la crise
aux frontières avec les chercheurs
d'asile et les migrants et la confusion
dans le public américain c'est les
différences entre les réfugiés les gens
dans les caps 2 au pnue partout dans le
monde et les migrants qui viennent à
leurs frontières et sans décision d'
apaiser la gauche du parti démocrate
peuvent lui coûter des votes dans les
étapes candiac c'est ce qu'ils vont
gagner des votes
après le sens ça veut dire concrètement
que cette décision qu'il a prise
est ce qu'elle est clairement réaliste
on a vu que ce n'était pas aussi évident
que ça ce n'est pas simplement un effet
d'annoncé aujourd'hui le pratique
lui-même et sont parce que les réfugiés
ne sont pas des chercheurs d'asile tout
seul à 6,1 procédures de vetting et le
nombre son petit chien parle de 72 mille
personnes
ses petits poings pieds de 300 nil mais
oui c'est une couac de communication
parce que actuellement en na'vi
colorisation sur le sujet des nouvelles
rentrées en un mouvement de doigt ou aux
états unis qui simplement vaucluse des
immigrés ni des réfugiés
ce soir une sorte de gazon dans les
flammes de le colère clairement cette
bataille enivré remporté par parlait
legault au chant des démocrates à ce
qu'elles ont présage d'autres avec la
maison blanche selon vous nous
précisément exemple dans notre projet
d'infrastructure c'est lui qui vraiment
quand c'est presque deux milliards de
dollars dans une bille et de toutes
sortes et à commande dépend cette agence
il est vrai enjeu offrir une
augmentation dans le nombre de réfugiés
important symboliquement mais ça coûte
ça très peu et ça donne très peu de
ressources qui nommera me congrès c'est
la capacité de amené à apporter de
l'argent de votre circonscription
hélas la gauche n'a pas beaucoup de
choses qu'il a demandé publiquement les
avec les systèmes de santé
mais non je pense que c'est une victoire
importante pour la gauche mais en
revanche il y aura plein des déceptions
à venir et à le long terme
aydin peut pas être un président
acceptable à la gauche du parti
démocrate
merci donc l'assiette sans d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur france pour
commenter ces deux et vingt deux
actualités aux états unis et un dernier
mot à présent sur le procès de georgia
flou et l'avocat de derek sherwin
demande l'annulation du verdict il met
en cause le jury pour comportement
inapproprié
on lui certains jurés n'auraient pas
fait preuve d'impartialité l'inquiète
donc un nouveau procès
médéric chauvine a été déclaré coupable
du meurtre de george ford afro américain
décédé à minneapolis après un contrôle
de police et condamné à quarante années
de prison et pour en parler nous sommes
en direct depuis houston avec dave
perkins analyse politique protruck passé
notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
[Musique]
bonsoir dave perkins merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors ce
procès c'est vrai a été ultra médiatisé
montré en parallèle de manifestations
anti raciste et anti violence policière
est-ce que cela a pu avoir une influence
sur le verdict comme le prétend l'avocat
de dave chauvine aujourd'hui déjà que
c'est le cas car un des jurés a dit dans
les médias qu'ils se sentent est inquiet
qu'il avait peur que sa famille qu'il
craignait que la foule se rendent chéri
que ces informations soient diffusées
auprès du public
il semblerait que les mêmes choses peut
arriver à beaucoup de personnes dans
beaucoup de lieux à cause de cette foule
qui voulait le verdict
dans un verdict très spécifique est
effectivement une zone cotonou lourd
verdict qu'il souhaitait car lui avait
peur de voter différemment
il n'a pas dit qu'il avait horrifié son
vote mais il a clairement dit qu'il
avait peur de la réaction de la foule
contre lui ou sa famille s'il avait voté
pour l'acquittement
donc il faut se demander combien les
autres jurés ressentez la même chose
sans le dire surtout après que maxime
blenders tel taux d'écouté et contribuer
à cette atmosphère en nous disant qu'il
fallait condamner derek chauvin un des
injures et a également pris part à des
rassemblements du plm est amorti
lorsqu'on lui a demandé ce qu'il faisait
si ils y avaient participé
donc c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles il a été sélectionné il a
donné une interview dans laquelle il a
dit qu'en tant que militant nous devons
être intégrés dans ces jurys pour
pouvoir influencer les résultats
donc c'est très clairement un mutant
béal m qui veut influencer le verdict
plutôt qu'un jury impartial
à cause de ces deux personnes on peut
donc suspecté que davantage de personnes
ont eu des comportements du même genre
et donc effectivement il pourrait y
avoir un deuxième procès clairement
perkins la défense de derek chauvine ne
cherche-t-elle pas à politiser le
verdict est déjà politisé et plaques
l'animateur s'en est assuré car certains
avocats ont essayé de revenir aux faits
et je pense que c'est une question de
politique ce verdict il n'avait pas
l'intention de tuer cet homme dont il
n'est pas coupable de meurtre bien qu'il
ait été arrogant qu'il est
et arras est cet homme mais cela n'est
pas du meurtre c'est un homicide
et c'est le seul chef d'inculpation qui
aurait dû être accepté donc il n'est pas
un meurtrier
vous parlez de ces manifestations est
évidemment de cette politisation on le
sert les policiers américains sont sous
pression depuis la ferme georges le feu
des manifestations qui ont suivi est ce
que clairement l'administration trump a
laissé pourrir ce malaise dans la police
n'aurait fait que si tu vois je pense
que c'est la situation dans les rues les
manifestations la violence les
destructions qui sont une tentative de
se débarrasser de donald trump ou
réparer il s'agissait d'assurer que je
donne à traves ne soit pas réélu ce sont
des réactions à la présence de l'al trup
à la maison blanche que la trump n'a pas
causé cela on ne veut pas lui reprocher
c'est une stratégie nationale par un
large groupe de personnes en colère afin
de s'assurer que notre homme ne soit pas
le fait qu'il ait été élu président a
scandalisé beaucoup de personnes à
gauche de ce point de vue là on pourrait
dire qu'il a causés mais on ne peut pas
dire qu'il ait provoqué ces
manifestations à part par le simple fait
qu'il était président et coke tant de
personnes les détester et ai voulu
s'assurer que ne soit pas réélu
aujourd'hui clairement l'arrivée de jupp
heynckes qu'elle à apaiser ces tensions
annoncées au bacon je ne pense pas ils
veulent ce qu'ils veulent et ce qu'ils
veulent
va au delà des limites de la loi de la
société de la culture
je ne pense pas que joe biden et ses
équipes puissent se permettre de céder
sur tous ces points et cela pourrait
causer une perte sont défaite lors des
élections suivantes dll d'extrême gauche
n'auront aucun repos tant que joe biden
n'accédera pas leur demande alors je
pense que la pression va augmenter tout
comme elle a augmenté face à donald
trump la bataille n'est pas finie
est-ce qu'on peut s'imaginer voir de
nouvelles émeutes comme y en a eu au
lendemain de la mort de georges floyd je
pense que c'est déjà le cas à simplement
les médias ne s'intéressent pas bhl
cours car les médias sont du côté des
démocrates et ils savent que les
américaines n'allaient pas voir ce genre
d'émeutes à la télévision n'est même pas
imaginer qu'elle arrive et imagine est
convoqué contre le parti qui le permet
lors des élections suivantes
donc ils minimisent ces émeutes ces
événements afin d'empêcher la couleur de
se développer contre le démocrate de
s'exprimer dans les urnes
mais oui il ya toujours des émeutes et
je pense que cela va continuer l'été
arrive et elle elle n'obtient pas
satisfaction de joe biden donc je pense
que la violence les manifestations
continueront dans l'avenir
merci beaucoup d'éleveurs perkins et
anaïs politique merci d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france et au
mexique les interrogations demeurent
après l'accident de métro à mexico qui a
fait lundi soir au moins 24 morts des
dizaines de blessés selon un dernier
bilan l'enquêté se poursuit pour
déterminer les responsables du drame
l'ancien maire de la capitale et actuel
ministre des affaires étrangères est mis
en cause françois xavier lambert
le calme est revenu aux alentours du
pont aérien en partie effondrée alors
que les travaux de déblayage des
décombres ont permis d'extraire la rame
de métro accidenté l'enquète se poursuit
pour comprendre les causes de la
tragédie
lundi soir l'effondrement de la
structure de 12 mètres de haut faisait
plonger dans le vide plusieurs wagons
lors d'une conférence de presse le
président mexicain a promis des
investigations impartiales
il va y avoir une enquête approfondie
sans égards d'aucune sorte pour chercher
à connaître la vérité
l'enquète pour homicide involontaire a
été confiée au bureau du procureur de
mexico mais déjà de nombreuses critiques
vie celui qui était le maire de la ville
lors de l'inauguration de cette ligne en
octobre 2012
marcelo ebrard d' l'actuel ministre des
affaires étrangères et potentiel
candidat à la présidence mexicaine
dès sa mise en service une usure des
rails et des roues des trains de cette
ligne avait été détectée plusieurs
accidents se sont également produits
dernière en date en janvier dernier
lorsqu'un incendie avait endommagé les
installations de contrôle du réseau
l'accident avait fait un mort et 29
blessés pour ces manifestants la
corruption et la négligence des
politiques ont conduit à ces drames
certains ont perdu des bras des mains
des membres
c'est de la négligence et cela peut
arriver dans n'importe quel autre ligne
de métro
c'est à cause de la corruption de
l'impunité du manque de soins pour ceux
d'entre nous qui vivent habite et
transitent dans la banlieue justice pour
les familles en attendant les
conclusions de l'enquêté près de quatre
millions et demi de passagers vont
continuer d'emprunter quotidiennement le
métro de la capitale mexicaine le
gouvernement a décrété trois jours de
deuil national
et c'est la fin de cette émission merci
de l'avoir suivi prochain point complet
sur l'actualité ce sera dans quelques
minutes à 22h avec pierre qui sa vie
hivernaux quant à moi j'aurai le plaisir
de le trouver et de vous retrouver
demain à 20 heures
[Musique]
bienvenue à novossibirsk nous sommes au
bord de la volga le plus long fleuve
d'europe
nous sommes chez vox harry
allons faire connaissance vous avez
choisi le jour là on est alors je suis
arrivé en 2005 pour étudier dernière
fois c'était en 2011 demande pas un
petit peu